One good thing about music is when it hits
you, you feel no pain.
Unless your eardrums and lungs explode.
Hello everyone, Julian here for DNews.
At worst, loud noises are an annoyance.
Your neighbor’s got the stereo cranked up,
a baby in a movie theater is crying, you live
near a police siren testing facility, whatever.
You’ll be irritated, but you’ll live.
OR WILL YOU???
Is it possible for a sound to be so loud,
it makes you dead?
The European Space Agency seems to think so.
The ESA actually has an array of four gigantic
horns at the Large European Acoustic Facility
in Noordwijk, the Netherlands.
If they crank it up to 11, the horns can produce
sound as loud as 154 decibels, which they
reckon could definitely burst your eardrums
right away and maybe cause serious damage
from long term exposure.
But those freaky deaky Dutch aren’t using
their Horn Section of Doom as a weapon, they’re
using it to see if satellites can withstand
the sound of a rocket launch.
See, sound is a mechanical wave caused by
oscillations in air pressure.
The greater the change in air pressure, the
higher the amplitude, the more energy it carries
and the louder we interpret that sound to
be.
If a sound is loud enough, or at the right
frequency, it can shake something to pieces.
This is why the space shuttle’s launch platform
would dump 350,000 gallons of water onto itself
during launch to dampen the sound and keep
it from damaging the shuttle.
Otherwise the 195 decibels the engines pumped
out would put too much stress on the shuttle's
wings.
As it happens, it’s speculated that 195
decibels is totally enough loudness to kill
you dead.
It’s thought the threshold is anywhere from
185 to 200 decibels.
Sound waves with that big of a pressure fluctuation
might damage your lungs, either forcing an
air bubble into your blood that would then
cause cardiac arrest, or by making your lungs
themselves pop.
Not a lot of research on this has been done,
though German researcher Jurgen Altmann showed
that a sound wave at 210 decibels caused lung
damage.
Research has been conducted on fish with and
without air bladders, to see if they were
injured by the loud sounds caused by pile
drivers…
The machines that pound bridge supports into
mud, not the wrestling move.
Indeed fish without air bladders showed no
injuries, while the two species with air bladders
were severely damaged by sound alone.
So, why doesn’t some mad scientist just
crank those ESA horns and create a devastating
sound gun?
I mean we’re already at 154 decibels, what’s
another 40?
Well, it’s not as easy as it sounds because
the decibel scale is a bit misleading.
People often quote that a conversation is
around 60 decibels, a rock concert is 115
decibels, and so on.
But what that explanation doesn’t tell you
is the decibel scale is logarithmic: a sound
at 90 decibels has 10 times the energy as
a sound at 80 decibels.
So to get those monstrous European horns to
lethal levels, the sound wave they generate
would need to have 10,000 times more energy
and the change in air pressure they cause
would be 100 times greater.
If you’d want to make someone’s head explode
a la Scanners, you’d probably have to have
100 times the amplitude again, going all the
way up to 240 decibels.
And keep in mind, you’d have to put the
person’s head right next to the sound source
for that to happen because sound dissipates.
I think it’s safe to say that while sound
can theoretically kill you, it’s probably
not going to happen…
Just don’t go wandering under any space
shuttle rockets without hearing protection.
Look, if you're one of those mad scientists
who ARE looking to weaponize sound and use
it for your own nefarious purposes you should
watch Trace's ancient DNews episode here.
Are there
any other things you think could be weirdly
fatal you want us to look into?